welcome back okay we've been talking
about dynamic mo decomposition with
control and I thought it would be fun to
code up a really simple example to
demonstrate what can go wrong if you
naively apply DMD and how you actually
implement the corrected DMD with control
so this example is actually directly
inspired from the example in Josh
Proctor's DMD with control paper and so
I'm going to walk you through it okay so
what we have here is a discrete-time
system where the a matrix is 0.9 0 0 1.1
so maybe I'll just run this and show you
what we get okay so this is the a matrix
0.9 and 1.1 in the diagonal
since this is a discrete-time system we
actually see that this is unstable
because one of the eigenvalues has
radius bigger than 1 so the x2
components going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger as it iterates through
this a map and I'm assuming that I have
a B matrix which is 0 1 so I can affect
that unstable eigen value and then I
have a controller some feedback control
which is U equals minus KX where I have
this gain matrix K and so my closed loop
system if I if I actually apply that
feedback control u equals minus KX then
my closed loop system is stable so
notice I literally just subtract 0.3
from this eigen value and I have to
stabilize values in my closed loop
system enacting that feedback control
okay so what what Josh Procter realized
and and he actually realized this in the
context of disease control where maybe
you have some really complicated natural
dynamics maybe they're unstable maybe
they're stable but you can't afford to
turn off your control strategy so that
you can do a system identification
that's that's kind of inhumane to just
stop vaccinating and stop treating
disease so that you can get a model of
the system and so what he wondered was
can you get a model of the underlying
dynamics and disambiguate the effect of
the underlying dynamics from the
actuation without actually turning off
the
control law okay so that's what we're
gonna do here is we're going to measure
the system with the closed-loop control
and we're going to compute naive DMD on
the data and then we're going to compute
the corrected DMD with control to try to
figure out what the true a matrix is
okay so that's the basic setup we have
an a matrix of B matrix and some
feedback control U equals minus KX let
me just put that in the comments u
equals minus K times X and so I'm going
to generate some data with an initial
condition 1010 so my X vector at time 1
is 1010 and then I'm going to go through
ten iterations of this dynamical system
so I'm going to say my feedback control
at time step K is U equals minus KX at
that same time step and then my next
time step XK plus 1 is a XK plus B u K
okay so a very simple for loop to just
step the system forward in time discrete
time dynamics and then what I'm going to
do is I'm going to plot my X variables
in time and you're going to see in fact
they do decay kind of linearly so
because I have this this feedback
control I can't see that one of these is
actually unstable dynamics because the
the controlled system is giving the
stable decay okay good all right so now
what I want to do is two things the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to code up a naive DMD where I don't
know that there's a control input I'm
just going to do DMD on this closed loop
system and so to do that remember DMD is
super easy I just say x equals the first
one to n minus 1 snapshots 1 to n minus
1 and X 2 is going to be X 2 to end so
I'm taking the the first columns in X
everything up until the the second to
last column and for X prime or X 2 I'm
taking the second through the last
columns so X 2 is just a times X okay at
least that's what it should be
and then I can compute a let's call this
a naive equals x2 times the
pseudo-inverse of X okay
now if I was doing real DMD on a high
dimensional state I'd have to do some
additional steps I'd have to project
this onto singular vectors and extract
the modes but since this is a two-state
system and I have more measurements in
time than States I can just do this
simple pseudo inverse and so when I run
this what I find is the naive a estimate
is my closed loop a model with stable
eigen values so if I only do this on
uncontrolled data and I don't take into
account the fact that this U is actually
stabilizing the system then my DMD a
matrix in correctly identifies the
closed loop dynamics and not the actual
original unstable a matrix okay but we
can actually correct for this so let's
now make a new one called correct DMDC
model and so now what we're going to do
we have the same X and the same x2 now
we're going to build an OOP salon
variable and that's just my you okay so
they're just the time snapshots of you
and now my correct a I'll say a correct
what I'm going to do since I know my B
vector I'm going to assume that I know
what my B vector was I can correct for
that in x2 so now I can do x2 minus B
times Epsilon
that's my new kind of corrected x2 and I
can now do pseudo inverse of X okay so
all I've done is because I can measure
my actuation you and I know what my B
vector is I can get this corrected
dynamic so I can essentially subtract
that plus bu off onto the left hand side
so now I have X prime minus B epsilon
equals a times X and so now I'm going to
pseudo inverse X to find my my best a
matrix and when I do this my DMD with
control this is the DMD control a matrix
I
the correct original system model with a
stable and unstable eigenvalue okay so
this is just kind of a very very simple
toy example this is the one that Josh
put in his paper to illustrate what can
go wrong if you naively apply DMD and
how you can correct for it if you know
oops along your control inputs and you
know be your actuation signal now if I
didn't know B this would be a little bit
more complicated there would be more
steps in here and I would also have to
to give my system a few more kind of
kicks or some add some white noise on my
control input to simultaneously discover
a and B but you can see that in this
case where I know the B vector it's
really really easy to get the true
underlying a matrix and I might want to
do this because if I if I did DMD naive
DMD on my data I might think I didn't
have any problem that there was no
instability and I might not under
understand the basic underlying physics
of this this unstable system whereas if
you do this this corrected DMD with
control procedure you learn very quickly
that your actual system has an unstable
eigenvalue and so if you were going to
change your control strategy you should
take this into account okay so very
simple to cook up an example in MATLAB
where regular DMD doesn't work because
you're forcing the system but where DMD
with control gives you the correct
underlying dynamics okay thank you